Speaker 1: Hey, David, I saw an article that
Australia is now ranking soda as healthier
than fruit juice.
What do you think?
Is soda healthier than fruit juice?
This is not a nutritionist type show.
And I'm just going to give you my opinion
based on everything that I've read.
It is true that if you go simply buy a grams
of sugar, you could make the case that fruit
juice is less healthy than soda in the sense
that it is laden with more grams of sugar.
Now, if you are getting the sugar from naturally
occurring fruit, sugar versus, for example,
high fructose corn sirup in a soda, my instinct
is that the fruit sugar is probably preferable.
But that being said.
There's an interesting story about how orange
juice got branded as a healthy part of a balanced
breakfast, and the reality is that squeezing
the juice only out of a fruit like an orange
and having the juice of what I mean, a glass
of juice is what the juice of three oranges
for orange is something like that, absent
the fiber and nutrients of the pulp doesn't
seem particularly healthy.
Now, if you say, you know, I don't I don't
really drink fruit juice, I'll occasionally
make a juice at my house and it'll be like,
you know, one of these beet carrot, orange
apple juices, it's half vegetable juice or
whatever.
I don't think it's the healthiest thing, but
OK, in the summer I may indulge.
I haven't had soda and I don't even know how
long other than the occasional foreign coke,
which is sweetened with sugar instead of corn.
Sirup if you give me the choice, I'm probably
still choosing the juice, maybe in a smaller
portion than than what others might.
But the point is, I understand the Australian
health star ratings are focused exclusively
on sugar content, meaning grams of sugar.
And under that paradigm, you could make the
case that the soda is better.
It it's it doesn't really pass the sniff test
for me, particularly because the source of
a lot of those sugars in soda, combined with
all of the other ingredients, don't strike
me as healthier.
So my suggestion is just eat whole fruit,
eat an actual fruit, and instead of orange
juice for breakfast, maybe have an actual
orange or a half orange or half a grapefruit
or something like that.
My, my this is not advice, but I stick to
water.
Unsweetened coffee drinks.
Tea with no sugar or occasionally a little
bit of honey and then just sparkling water
and don't need sodas in my life, and if I'm
having juice, it's my homemade juice, OK?
Oh, and just one other thought on this.
A lot of parents will start giving their kids
juice pretty young.
And I know two pediatricians and they've both
said disaster, disaster.
You are tuning the sweet tooth of kids really
young if you start giving them juice when
they are very little in terms of if if you
want to give juice, they say water it down
dramatically where it's sort of like a look
like juice colored, but it's at least half,
if not three quarters or 80 percent water.
I'm not a parent, but that seems quite reasonable
to me.
OK, so that's my answer.
Having no idea about this stuff and just answering
what people ask me.
Make sure that you are following me on the
new platform on which we are publishing content
and engaging bit Klout.
You can find it at David Pakman Dotcom Klout.
I am setting up a direct message channel directly
to me for our top 20 Pakman holders on bit
clout.
What does that even mean, if you're curious?
Go to David Pakman Dotcom bit Klout bit Cielo
and check it out.
We'll have more about it next week.
And we have a great bonus show coming up for
you in mere moments.
How do you get access to the bonus show?
If only it were simple?
It is.
You become a member at join Pakman Dotcom
Unidentified: and that's it.
See
you then.